thank you
[Music]
so history has recorded the first big
UFO sighting in the United States is
1947 in Roswell New Mexico very famously
right outside Roswell but actually there
was in some sense a bigger and more
significant event citing two years
before also New Mexico at exactly the
moment the US government was detonating
the first atomic weapon shortly
thereafter used in Japan and Witnesses
on the ground saw
some kind of object shaped like an
avocado they said crash land it was
inspected by a lot of locals there were
beings inside they said and it was
carted away by the US government now
people don't want to be called crazy so
no one said too much about it for quite
some years but people within the U.S
government believe it's true and they
believe it so strongly that now as of
this week the defense Department's
annual spending bill will require as per
Congress the Pentagon to go back and
investigate what really happened
Nick Pope is a former UK Ministry of
Defense official who's followed the
Civil very closely he joins us to assess
Nick thanks so much for coming on so
this is a story that most I think
Americans are not even aware of but
clearly people within the US government
believe it's real or they wouldn't have
attached this to a spending Bill correct
yes this is being called the Roswell
before Roswell and you're right people
with some knowledge of these
intelligence programs who've been
briefing Congress about this made sure
that this was put into the legislation
and it's some it's one of many UFO
Provisions in the new defense Bill the
dod must provide congress with a list of
everything they've found out about this
this specific incident but all other
incidents and programs from January 1st
1945 onwards and anyone involved in
these programs or with information about
it will be released from their secrecy
Oaths and non-disclosure agreements and
they'll be able to testify to Congress
about this
so here we have the nuclear connection
again this was around the first
detonation in in human history of a
nuclear device subsequent to that you've
had UFO sightings at nuclear missile
bases around nuclear-powered aircraft
carriers to compared submarines there's
a clearly some nuclear I mean I don't
pretend to understand but nuclear has
some connection to these sightings no
that seems to be the case and again uh
Congress is demanding answers on this we
had the latest report from the office of
the Director of National Intelligence uh
last week that highlighted the fact that
there were several hundred more
sightings being investigated military
sightings than we'd heard of uh before
talked about unusual flight
characteristics and performance
parameters of this and yeah we must get
to the bottom of this UFO and nuclear
connection
yeah I mean I would think it feels like
we're getting closer I hope Nick Pope
thank you for your work on this
appreciate it
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight